So young man from Turkey I have
often put myself in a royal Indian position
to see which variant he
chooses
H3,
a bit of experience from a white
perspective
at least and I was always a
bit
uncomfortable with the black E5 or C5, which is always
delayed,
now it's a really
strange mixture here
somehow  With the DM on
V8, it's pretty
strange. Yes, of course, white has a
nice
space advantage. It's quite possible that that
's quite good for
white anyway, but I don't know how to
play it differently
and I just didn't want to think about it forever.
Yes, it has a good space advantage
The lady here is a
problem and has to
bring it back somehow. F4 is just a
problem now, it's really so hard to
push everything forward or G5 is my
opinion and then
F4
looks really
dangerous.
E5 would also be another idea, maybe
so, I'll play completely
I can't do knight D7 straight away now,
I think because of
F5. First of all,
here's another setup like this.
In retrospect, you have to
ask yourself whether bishop E6 was such a
good idea here. Um,
knight die7 doesn't work again,
so I have to  here
I hope that F5 is prevented at least
for a moment, I
don't like it, but I'm actually quite happy
if they
swap things around so now maybe you can
get counterplay here, after all he ca
n't play B4 because of Queen
B6,
otherwise he would have  a pawn lost
again because of Queen B6 but that's
structurally quite interesting
actually,
so it stands against F5 again and
also attacks H3,
not directly but that could be an
idea
then so now maybe rook rook to
C5 yes, that's okay  but you ca
n't take well either, I
actually thought A2 h D with check, that's
not a
problem, spread tur B8
in front or rook
A8 now I've allowed F5, I do
n't know if it's bad,
but
maybe that way we really get
the knight  back again to the
if he takes knight E6 I have
fields again so
okay
so here I also have a
field at the end there is A2 again if he
now
takes B7 and turma 3 is now an idea
that would also be an idea  been a
moment but now it has to
be good now everything is on the
third
row
so right next to it I can't use
C3 yet but I can
play with the idea of ​​D with D4
maybe and then go to F4
or go straight to the rook  the fourth row
how does he cover
F4 has a check down here
yes
check
now G5 is still hanging
so now it doesn't have checkmate
somehow
I don't see checkmate but that has to
be checkmate somehow I'm so blind now
here probably
a
check
check after all  only found one
Checkmate yes, suddenly there were a
lot of counter chances there, it was
definitely good at the beginning but he
lost the thread so that from Queen
B3 onwards it wasn't so optimal anymore
he just really has the king
completely open, it was definitely white beforehand
good